loin à l'est par delà des mots et des
rivières se dresse un pic solitaire les
nains sont résolus à reconquérir leurs
terres j'aime avoir des visiteurs comme
n'importe quel hobbit mais j'aime bien
les connaître avant qu'ils ne me rende
visite
monsieur sackey servi et où je suis en
cours et denain que font-ils ici bien
joyeuse assemblée alors c'est le hobbit
vous m'aviez demandé de trouver le 14e
membres de cette compagnie j'ai choisi
monsieur sa came - non non non mais ho
bits peuvent passer inaperçu quand ils
le veulent
ce qui nous donne un net avantage nous
saisirons cette chance de reprendre pour
une aventure litres en dire pourquoi
elle se mit en pourquoi bilbon sacquet
peut-être est-ce parce que j'ai peur et
qu'il me donne du courage
ainsi c'est là votre but
pénétrez dans la montagne et alors donc
je voudrais que cela n'est pas prudent
puissance magnifique à trouver un moyen
de revenir dans le monde
et si nous jouions aux jeux des énigmes
simples caresses qu'il est super mon
précieux nous le montrons nous inquiète
énormément j'en doute prendre sous
entendus
je n'échangerais aucun de ces la rendre
la plus puissante des harnais
loyauté power incurvation je me demande
pas plus
votre village est derrière vous
désormais les demandes des deux ans
à
rebbah ça aurait pu être pire
non mais tu puisses ans j'espère